anytime i get
that that feeling of anger is it's
usually in a ufc
situation so i had i haven't i haven't
been in a street fight since daniel
cormier
i don't get any arguments face to face
in the arena a few years ago back in i'm
not sure what year that was but
yeah dude beat him that was on the first
one
yeah the first fight yeah the first time
we faced off uh we went for head to
forehead and he chopped me in the throat
i ended up pushing him over
tackling him off the stage it was crazy
i thought i got the best of him he ended
up taking off his dress shoe and
winging it across the room trying to hit
me in the face to get the last lick and
ended up hitting a female reporter
in the head instead it was crazy that's
not good
moments later we go backstage and we get
in this heated argument and then that's
when there's this famous hole are you
still there [ __ ] hey [ __ ] are you
still there have you ever heard that
line no he's like i just want to [ __ ]
spit in your face yeah yeah damn for
cormier is like
i will end you i was like i absolutely
kill you yeah if you do that he's like
you think i'm just going to sit there
and let you kill me john jones the whole
argument when
it was people freaking reenacted all the
time people love that
it was fun that's what it's all about
and i gotta confess too that that
is uh like clearly like
2016 or before right because i only
really
became like the diehard ufc fan
like around that time and since and i
guess that doesn't make me very die hard
but
man i don't miss a fight dude man we
appreciate you man that's huge
i don't miss a fight and i love it dude
are you are you you and john are you in
uh
are you in dc cool now or just yeah i
respect dc
i i i think he's an outstanding man i i
think he represents himself very well
i think he represents uh
african-americans very well i think he
represents father the ufc
very well being a father being an
athlete um
you know he's very well spoken he's a
great commentator get ready this is
going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready yeah
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you gonna piss me
off